what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are wrapping up stories that we started
and never had a chance to finish as
always make sure you guys subscribe and
drop a like if you're enjoying the
content and so let's get into it with
the conclusion of Venom Vol 1. now this
is a really really a cool story right
this is one of the things I love about
this conclusion is that what this does
is it actually focuses on Meridius now
it's been a while since we covered Venom
so don't worry I'm not going to leave
you hanging Not Gonna Leave You confused
about what's going on we won't make
sense of everything but one of the
things that you guys will notice here
and we talked about this in the previous
video is that Meridius basically had an
agenda that was not fully fleshed out we
don't really know what this guy's
motivation is all we know is he
basically showed up in the present day
from the far-flung future and
essentially created a symbiote out of
himself named Bedlam and then in turn
released Bedlam into the world with the
intention of going after Eddie Brock's
son Dylan and that's one of the things
to keep in mind here is that in the
aftermath of the king and black story
that Eddie Brock had basically bonded
with all of the Symbiotes he had become
a in black meaning he can control all
the different symbiotes that exist
Across the Universe and he would use
them to basically fight crime or to deal
with major calamities and things like
that across the universe itself like
having his own Universe wide personal
Army but the thing behind this is that
what it did is it left his son Dylan
Brock back on Earth largely feeling
abandoned and alone and so that seems to
be part of the scheme of Meridius but
what's more intriguing here is that
following him unleashing the Bedlam
symbiote onto Earth he basically travels
back to his own time and when he gets
there it's just this enormous Garden
that exists but he also ends up finding
the body of Eddie Brock which has
emerged in this island now that's one of
the things to remember is that there was
a point in the previous stories that we
did when Dylan was visited by what
seemed to be Eddie Brock who basically
told him we have to pack we have to get
out of here right we're gonna go to a
motel uh and then we're gonna get things
sorted from there right like people are
after me again or something along those
lines and where Dylan had actually
called Eddie Brock that basically led to
Eddie saying yes go to the motel but do
not bond with the Symbiote the
implication being that it was Dylan who
was talking to the Symbiote in the house
and it was actually Eddie Brock that he
was talking to on the phone but at the
end of the day Eddie Brock the physical
real tangible Eddie Brock was destroyed
when the motel exploded and so because
he was basically dead this is where he
washed up at this is where his body
showed up at where he basically meets
with Meridius now the cool thing about
this is that as they're walking through
and that's really kind of all you need
to know for at least this next little
bit of a story but as they're walking
through this place Eddie Brock has all
kinds of questions like what in the
world is this place and what we're told
is that this is referred to as the
garden of time and it was given that
name by seemingly Meridius and named
after a guy named Ballard who had
written a story about a man who
controlled time but who could not turn
back what was coming basically stopped
some kind of an apocalypse That was
supposed to be coming to their doors and
what he effectively says here is that
this place that they're in this Garden
of time is basically at the very end of
time it's the last of all things the
only things that wait for them are quite
literally the cosmic entities Oblivion
and entropy the end of basically
everything but then Eddie Brock starts
to pick up on the general look of this
place and the general feel of this place
and comes to the realization that it's
all synthetic and that's when Meridius
is like yes this is what the Symbiote
hive mind becomes that unlike in your
time in 2022 where the Symbian hive mind
is basically just a whole bunch of
Symbiotes that can communicate with each
other and this time here at the end of
everything the Symbiotes are basically
dormant they're effectively sleeping but
because of the power that people like
you and I possess we can reshape the
Symbiotes without waking them up and
turn them into virtually anything we
want to and that makes sense that
actually makes perfect sense because
while we didn't necessarily see Venom do
it all that often if at all there are
symbiotes out there that can shape-shift
and the reality here is that if one
symbiote can shape-shift all symbiots
can shape-shift either they don't know
that they can do it or they just simply
haven't done it yet but whatever the
reason is symbiotes can physically
become anything they are a sort of
amorphous blob that takes the form of a
kind of Goo that bonds itself to a
person but they can look or be basically
anything they want to now when the
question is asked by Eddie Brock how did
this thing get to the way that it was
the response of Meridius is I shaped it
right I took this sort of symbiote hive
mind and I shaped it to make it look
this way basically I'm the reason that
it is and the result of this is Eddie
comes to the realization that Meridius
can quite literally plug into the
Symbiote hive mind now the last time
that Eddie Brock saw anybody do that it
was the the actual King in Black right
like the being who created the Symbiotes
in the first place that's the last time
he saw anybody who was able to tangibly
plug into the hive mine and control it
and that's what he asks him he's like so
like are you null are you like some
future version of null the Symbiote God
and the response of Meridius is no but I
am a king in black as are you you are
definitively a king in Black of the
Venom symbiotes now this is kind of a
funny thing here because this sort of
requires us to know what had come before
in order to understand what's going on
now and like we said earlier when Eddie
Brock had based basically taken over I
guess the governing or he ruled all the
Symbiotes after the destruction and the
death of null that's what turned him
into the king in Black so at the time
when that story concluded we treated it
as more like a ceremonial title like
Steve Rogers becoming Captain America
Odin's son becoming Thor that kind of a
thing the reality here is that's not the
case that it is a title that's given to
him but it's given to him by virtue of
being the person who's able to control
all the Symbiotes in existence and
that's what makes him the king in Black
not only that there are other kings in
Black that exist as well one of the
things that we're told for example is
that there's somebody named wild who
becomes a king in Black after Eddie
Brock presumably after Eddie Brock
actually dies like he just dies of old
age or whatever the case is and in fact
there is another person named Tyro who
becomes a king in Black after wild so
basically it's one of these things where
even after Eddie Brock dies and
presumably Dylan dies as well that
somebody else ends up taking over the
role of controlling all the Symbiotes in
existence Across the Universe and it
just literally becomes a lie line of
succession now how those people are
chosen were not entirely sure we don't
know if it's some kind of a Calamity if
it's that the Venom symbiote basically
ends up losing its hosts like Eddie
Brock who dies for whatever reason it
bonds himself to Wild and then wild
becomes a new King in Black wild dies
and then the Venom Cindy it bonds itself
to Tyro we don't even know if it's the
Venom Symbian it's one of the things to
keep in mind here is that because
Venom's kind of always been the star
when it came to the Symbiotes and Marvel
Comics that the Venom sibia kind of
seems to be the one that leads sort of
like the top symbiote the field
commander if you want to call it that
but it's just one of those things where
we're kind of given this explanation
that there are more people out there
like Eddie Brock who Take Over Control
of the Symbiotes and who wield
insurmountable amounts of power now this
is where things get a little bit murky
and the reason why is because Eddie and
Meridius continue this conversation and
he's introducing him to everybody else
Meridius says in this Eddie as you
guessed wild he's a king as well who
obviously came here the same way that
you did and that's when you basically
have this statement this time damn and
where they say he means by unshackling
your mind from the flow of time and we
don't really get any any more of an
explanation other than that I mean we
kind of do to a degree in the sense that
Meridius says like I apologize for them
interrupting like that I do try to teach
those who wash up here to navigate the
currents of time but mostly so they
leave me alone it can be frustrating
we're all Kings but that doesn't make us
friends the reason why this matters and
the reason why we don't really get any
more of an explanation by uh for that is
because suddenly like the Bedlam
symbiote shows up and we'll talk about
him here in a second but the thing
behind this and the way they phrase it
here washing up in this location you
don't hear them saying things like he
got here the same way you did Meridius
brought you here instead what seems to
go on is that whenever a person becomes
a king in Black regardless of how long
they were a king in Black they basically
seem to show up here when they die the
most obvious question to ask in relation
to that statement is well then where is
null the Symbiote God and I don't have
an answer to that question I don't know
the answer to that question and that's
why I say this is purely speculation
it's one of the things Al Ewing does Al
Ewing will like give you a piece of
information and then leave it and then
like suddenly the tables will turn or
some event will transpire and it'll just
kind of be left and you know asking that
question wait wait I need to know this
but he's going to tie into it later on
in the midst of this conversation
basically the Bedlam symbiote shows up
here not only that but we're met by the
arrival of another king and black named
Finnegan now the arrival of Finnegan
basically Heralds the arrival of bedlam
in the sense that we're not given a
whole lot of information about Bedlam
and because Bedlam is a king in Black
what it looks like or at least that
seems to be the case what it looks like
is basically Meridius had summoned
Bedlam from potentially this location to
earth when he initially Unleashed him on
earth now again we don't really know the
ins and outs of battle all we simply
know is that the Symbiote is basically
just here so it could be that it's just
a symbiote and not a king in black but
the reason why I say the arrival of
Finnegan basically means the arrival of
bedlam is because Bedlam hates Finnegan
quite literally Bedlam absolutely lutely
hates Finnegan and in fact a fight
breaks out between the two or really
it's more Bedlam intending to eat
Finnegan now of course Eddie Brock jumps
in and Eddie Brock attacks Bedlam and
that's when you get this little bit of a
statement by Meridius when he's
initially asked like are you going to
step in his response is like it doesn't
really matter and what seems to be the
case here is that nobody in this realm
can actually really die that if Eddie
Brock was seemingly destroyed he would
basically be reborn in some capacity we
don't necessarily know again we're not
definitively given an answer here what
we are told though is that despite
everything that we've ever seen Eddie
Brock do over the course of Marvel
Comics none of it matters in relation to
the power of bedlam Bedlam absolutely
crushes Venom I mean literally rips his
arm off like just overpowers this guy
and he never really had a chance in the
first place and that's the thing like
you have this statement where Meridius
is like God look at those cavemen go
right and even when he's asked like you
know why don't you just step in like why
don't you break up all this stuff the
response of Meridius is why should AI
right we're Kings and black mines
without bodies and a garden of bodies
without Minds let the gods splatter if
that's how Bedlam wants to ease his
tensions it won't hurt anybody so again
this seems to hit to the idea that none
of them can actually die here that
because they are basically Minds right
they take on a kind of physical form of
their own that when Eddie Brock's mind
arrived here it was not actually a
physical body instead he basically
manifested a physical body out of the
Symbiote matter that already existed
here so if Bedlam just consumes and
destroys Eddie Brock all it's gonna do
is just destroy a physical body and
Eddie Brock's mind will simply reform a
new one and everything will be fine
that's basically just how things go now
of course while Eddie Brock is facing
off against Bedlam Finnegan basically
tells them no no it's cool man just go
ahead and attack him right go ahead and
kill him now the crazy thing about this
is that Finnegan had tried to tell Eddie
Brock something before he was
immediately attacked by Bedlam but when
this happens Finnegan basically tells
Medlin go ahead and kill Eddie Brock
right that's fine and of course Eddie's
sort of taken by surprise but with
better realizing Finnegan's still there
Bedlam grabs Finnegan he basically
destroys him where at least jumps up
into the sky and seems to kill him now
that's the kicker here is because one of
the statements that's made by these guys
who are here at least when they're
talking to Meridius is they point out
this idea that the truth of this
situation is that that Meridius is
trapped here just like they are so while
we could look at this as potentially
being a kind of afterlife for those
individuals who bond to a symbiote and
then go on to become a king in Black
then it actually looks like it's more of
a prison but we don't really know what
all is going on here we don't know if
it's one of these things where Marvel's
going to pan out and it's going to turn
out to be some snow globe or something
like that right we don't really know
what's going on with this situation and
things are incredibly murky but the
important thing here is that with all of
this unfolded it was really Al Ewing
kind of giving us a perspective of what
could go on or what does go on with
regards to Meridius and like the other
kings in black and how Eddie Brock fits
into it all and so ultimately Meridius
basically just leaves and one of the
things he does is he just kind of Muses
to himself where he actually ends up
kind of going back in time going back by
a few hours or so and even just sort of
observing things but he comes to this
realization that the reality here is he
needs to ensure that Eddie Brock comes
here and the reason why what's really
interesting here is that historically
speaking of Marvel Comics they treat the
future as an absolute thing until it's
not so for example if you look at the
X-Men the events of days of future past
when the Sentinel program was
reactivated by humans who were basically
terrified of mutants that the Sentinels
had taken over the entirety of North
America and they enslaved both humans
and mutants that was a guaranteed future
outcome that was going to happen until
you basically had Kitty Pride he went
into the past and prevented Days of
Future Past from happening and then the
future went back to any number of
possibilities right to jump to whatever
the next Calamity was going to be so the
point that I'm making here is that in
Marvel Futures are basically guaranteed
until something comes along that stops
that potential feature from happening
and then it becomes more fluid again and
so the reason why this is important is
because in this moment Meridius knows
that Eddie Brock shows up here in the
garden of time or seemingly the end of
all things for those individuals who are
Kings and black but any number of things
could happen that could result in that
not happening right any number of things
could take place that could result in
Eddie Brock not dying in that hotel
maybe he calls Dylan part way through
and says actually let's meet somewhere
else maybe something happens and he's
called away and he ends up just never
showing up to the to the motel any
number of things could take place so in
order to ensure that happens and this is
where things again get a little murky
here Meridius basically goes back to the
past and impersonates Eddie Brock so
when we saw that symbiote emerge in the
house of Eddie where Dylan was staying
and we thought well maybe it was this
symbiote or maybe it's somebody else
that we're not fully aware of it was
Meridius it was Meridius impersonating
Eddie Brock and telling Dylan we have to
go to a motel now that's the power this
guy possesses and that's something that
I hope you're starting to pick up on
that basically Meridius is someone out
there who was possessed by a Symbian and
then seemingly became the last king in
Black that there are no other King King
in Blacks after him and that he has has
completely and totally mastered he's
literally spent Ten Thousand Years
mastering the abilities of the Symbiotes
he is potentially even more powerful
than null the Symbiote God and that in
his ability to master the Symbiotes and
master The Garden of time he's also
learned how to master traveling back and
forth through the time stream and that's
why this place basically seems to be a
trap is because he even had told Eddie
like you can go home once you learn to
navigate the time stream and Meridius
has done that yet he still can't escape
the garden of time he seems to basically
be irrevocably stuck there he can't
quote unquote go home if we wanted to
call it that so again that's why I kind
of look at it as more of a prison than
anything else but literally he does this
because he wants to ensure that whatever
plan he's concocting comes to fruition
we don't really know the details of that
plan but we know that it does involve
ensuring that Eddie Brock dies in front
of Dylan and that Dylan in his anger in
his rage by not only having been
abandoned by his father when he took off
into space to become a superhero and
manage all the Symbiotes Across the
Universe but that he now feels
permanently abandoned by his father
because basically Eddie Brock died
before he had a chance to really spend
much time with Dylan that based on the
comics that we read so far it fills
Dylan with a lot of rage and a lot of
anger not just towards Eddie but towards
the world itself and it even permeates
into the Venom symbiote and so it's one
of those things where as Meridius is
downstairs listening to Dylan call Eddie
Brock the question that he sort of poses
here and this is a real Mindbender is he
poses the question is it actually Eddie
Brock that Dylan is talking to or is it
Meridius who's pretending to be Eddie
Brock from some point where he travels
back to that moment in time in order to
ensure that Dylan actually goes to the
motel because remember he's trying to
make sure that these events unfold
exactly the way that they're supposed to
and that's why I say things are a little
murky because Al Ewing doesn't really
give us an explanation here Al Ewing
doesn't tell us if everything that
transpired up to the moment when Eddie
Brock showed up on the shore of the
garden of time and if that just happened
organically without anybody intervening
in any capacity it's just the way things
progress over the course of that period
of time and that Meridius is going back
here and ensuring things progress that
way or if things happen that way because
Meridius went back in time right like we
don't know if that's the case and our
viewing doesn't really give us an answer
it's just kind of left to us to
hypothesize or maybe just even keep it
in the back of our head just to see what
happens but the significant thing here
and what seems to be the overarching
plan of Meridius is to basically get his
hands on the Symbiote which is kind of
interesting because even when he says
like with everything that's happening
here that ultimately the Venom symbiote
will shed its name just like virtually
anything else does and on that day we
will be Venom and so what this looks
like is we can interpret it a couple
different ways either this is actually
Dylan Brock in the far-flung future this
is what Dylan becomes this just Ultra
powerful symbiote character maybe it's
somebody that has nothing to do with
with Dylan and it's also a potential
here that the Venom symbiote is wholly
unique and among all the other symbiotes
and is arguably the most powerful and so
the goal of Meridius is to actually
attain the Venom symbiote for himself
and then essentially do whatever it is
that he ends up doing which judging by
this look on his face where he's all
just you know kind of crazy looking
maybe it's horrifying right maybe he
already has the Venom symmet and he's
just guaranteeing his own future again
it's the nature of Al Ewing we don't
definitively know but we will find out
as time goes on so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace